la rumeur de la semaine brad pitt et
marion cotillard se verrait en secret et
ça ce sont des informations closer si
vous l'avez acheté cette semaine alors
quoi s'agit-il on a ici la photo la
preuve
voilà ah non c'est pas ça non c'est pas
ça
là la
chose lui
alors tu vois c'est l'histoire alors eh
ben elle est mal parlé sur ce plateau
parce qu'on en avait déjà parlé dans
closer au mois de février dernier brad
pitt était à paris où vous souvenez
propriétaires s'ils avaient même eu un
rendez vous secret avec jennifer aniston
oui c'était vues à l'hôtel costes a fait
14 février n'est pas sain voilà
seulement il s'était fait sa petite
visite culturelle avec roselyne bachelot
lourds etc et on a appris récemment que
dans son calendrier très chargé il avait
accordé un petit bout de son temps à
marion cotillard fois dans le haut
péninsule à un bel hôtel parisien parce
qu'ils avaient co signé avec l1 sont
restés très proches à louis-ii nuit à 6
ans sur un film un film de rohmer du
robert zemeckis ils ont tourné tous les
deux depuis sont restés très proches ils
s'appellent beaucoup quand ils peuvent
se voir il se voit
l'ironie du sort veut d'ailleurs qu'à
l'époque marion cotillard avait été
accusé d'être celle qui avait précipité
la rupture avec ces gars là il avait
d'ailleurs été obligé de faire un
communiqué m
guillaume canet de sa vie elle était
enceinte de son deuxième enfant et
rivera jeudi l'ironie pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui bon et 2 serait une
rupture la wii et que guillaume canet à
la wii voilà voilà donc ce sont des
retrouvailles au mois de février qui ont
été acquis on va faire croire quand même
que le mec revient à paris ils voient
que des bombes il revoit jennifer
aniston dans un hôtel l'hôtel costes le
14 février hôtels chambres 14 février
ils ont pas dormi lady de données il en
a pas dormi non la non ils ont fait quoi
en six et ils sont 100 m
oui mais moi moi moi je vais te baiser
changement sans fâcher le
mécénat oui voilà c'est le type a connu
la libye ce oui mais si tu m'as au
costes à paris dîner suite signé puis
repart tranquillement fatigue obligés de
faire grimper au troisième et c'est bon
ça ça me coûte rien mais dean et moi
en compte anna mais quand même non mais
je pense que ce type de couple en fait
c'est un fantasme pour tout public c'est
à dire qu'ils sont tellement beau
tellement glamour lui américain la plus
plus grands acteurs américains elle la
plus grande actrice française on a très
envie de boire ensemble après là
honnêtement florian danois grand chose
du néant alors qu'on n'a pas de titre et
ouais sur une sur un avion
utilisé en photo et on sait qu'ils se
connaissent
pardon mais brad pitt qui a travaillé
tout paris me voir brad pitt building
drivera quel hôtel quotidien paris bâle
et ending slovénie c'est là bas qu'ils
leur bonne semaine à jos à jour si rien
même si je peux très bien
mais il était au meurice je les avais il
peut changer par exemple il attendait
fanon entre femmes
telle qu elle a vu marion cotillard au
peninsula
je suis allé me souviens à besançon
j'avais besoin formule 1 tous les fans
s'étaient passés le
canada se déplacer
à montreux au festival de montreux j'y
suis allé avec tous montrent eux
s'étaient passé le mot ouais en bas du
grand palais où tu dormais parce que moi
j'étais dans la pauvreté elle et lui
étaient dans gros grand sud profond et b
étaient tous envers les mathieu mathieu
7 avr et des mecs qui s'avérèrent vous
passez votre vie ensemble mais oui c'est
un coup droit
non